So overall, Sam I think did
a great job with the interview.
Again, it's not important that
you get everything right.
I think you hit on the things that I
thought were important in the interview.
So being able to have knowledge
of intents and services, and
those things were important and maybe
a sense of use everyday in all your
applications, but at least he has
a good knowledge and a grasp for that.
His solutions, I think sometimes
when you ask people these very
open ended questions, they freeze.
So he has some creative
solutions I think, but
I kept kind of probing and
like, what else could happen?
He did a great job there.
I would have liked if he followed up
with more questions like I've made some
questions very vague and
he asked some follow up questions, but
I think there's plenty
more to kind of touch on.
Again it's just important when you don't
have a very well structured problem,
there is structure, but
the interviewer has that knowledge and
some of the concepts, you could tell
he's used in the past like there
are some things about
Android that he used but
he did not quite understand like maybe
the names or some of the concepts.
So I think kind of making sure that
you can resolve this thing that
you've done in Android to the name of it
is as important as well, but overall,
I think Sam did a great job and he's
the type of developer we wish to hire.